crowds traffic tourists taking selfies
another normal day in the heart of
London it will be the last one for weeks
or months a Samba Prime Minister telling
us that all our lives are about to
change
coronavirus is accelerating rapidly and
so is the government response now is the
time for everyone to stop non-essential
contact with others and to stop all
unnecessary travel we need people to
start working from home where they
possibly can and you should avoid pubs
clubs theaters and other such social
venues the gravity of the situation
edged into the PM's faces he asked us to
put normal life on hold
entire families instructed to stay at
home for 14 days if anyone has a
temperature or a cough if you or anyone
in your household has one of those two
symptoms then you should stay at home
for 14 days that means that if possible
you should not go out even to buy food
or essentials and for the elderly those
with serious health conditions and
pregnant women and even more drastic
measure in a few days time by this
coming weekend it will be necessary to
go further and to ensure that those with
the most serious health conditions are
largely shielded from contact from
social contact for around 12 weeks all
of this voluntary for now that could
change - this is quite a big step change
from where we were even four days ago
but in other Western European countries
in the US they're going further still
there states of emergency cities
enforced lockdown families been asked to
stay at home even if they are not ill
schools closed
are these the sorts of measures you
think the public should expect in the
next few days well that's just on where
we
in relation to two others don't forget
that if other countries are in different
stages in in their movement up the up
the curve and we've always made it very
clear that the crucial thing is
timeliness when you come to more extreme
measures like you know curfews and so on
and so forth you'll see in some of the
other countries you know we're keeping
all measures under review the days and
weeks ahead will be like nothing we've
known for decades I can't remember
anything like it in in my lifetime I
don't have really been anything like it
in in in peacetime and we have to accept
that it's a very considerable
psychological behavioral change that
we're asking you we're asking the the
public the nation to do a global
pandemic that now requires a wartime
effort from us all today our lives
changed they will change even more Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster